it I mean your book in general the the
way you lead is very much about we and
us you know the the power of we but is
there times when a leader has to step in
and be almost autocratic take control
make hard unpopular decisions oh I am
sure you know the answer to that and and
it is yes
yeah you know because I actually
um a there's a leader for a time but
then there's a leader for a situation
right and so I've had to do plenty of
unpopular things I think anytime you
have to run a company that endures a
century and has to enter another Century
you will do unpopular things you have no
choice and I often felt I had to
sacrifice things for the long term and
whether that would have been you know
really difficult things like you know
job changes or reductions or whether it
would be things like hey you know we're
going to change the way we do our
semiconductors and a whole different
philosophy
you have no choice I mean and in times
of Crisis as well you got to be I wish
that it's not a popularity contest so
that's none of these jobs are popularity
contests I don't care if your company's
got one person or half a million they're
not popularity contests but
psychologically is it difficult to to
just sort of step in as a new CEO and
to because you're fighting against
tradition against all these people that
act like Experts of their thing and they
are experts of their thing to step in
and say we need to do differently when
you got to change a company
it's really tempting to say throw
everything else out back to that what
must endure right yeah but I know when I
took over to start I knew how much had
to change more I got into it I could see
wow a lot more had to change right
because we needed a platform we'd always
done our best when we had a platform a
technology platform you will go back in
time and you'll think of the Mainframe
systems you'll think of the PC You'll
Think of perhaps middleware you know you
could even call services a platform we
needed a platform the next platform here
to be there
um skills when I took over if I we
inventored who had modern skills for the
future it was two out of 10 people for
the future not that they didn't have
relevant skills today but for the future
two out of ten yikes that's a big
problem right
um the the speed at which things were
getting done that has to so you got so
much to do and you say is that um is
that a scary thing yes do you have to
sometimes dictate yes but I did find and
it is worth it I know every big company
I know my good friend that runs General
Motors is she's had to change go back to
what is
them them you know and when you do that
that back to be essential we kind of
started with hey it's be essential then
the next thing I did with the team was
say okay now this means New Era of
computing new buyers are out there and
eh we better have new skills okay now
the next thing how do you operationalize
it and it just takes some time but you
can engineer that and get get people to
build belief and for the skills that
means uh that means hiring and it means
training you
oh boy that's a long skills is a really
long Topic in and of itself I try to put
my view in it I learned a lot and I
changed my view on this a lot
um
I'll go back at my very beginning say 40
years ago I I would have said
at that point okay I was always in a
hurry I was I was interviewing to hire
people I don't know how you hire people
40 years ago I'd be like okay I gotta
fit in these interviews I gotta hire
someone to get this done okay then time
would go on I'm like oh that's not very
good in fact someone once said to me hey
hire the best people to work for you and
your job gets a lot easier okay I should
spend more time on this topic I spend
more time on it then it was like okay
hire experts okay okay hired a lot of
experts over my life
and then I was really like an epiphany
and it really happened over my tenure
running the company and having to change
skills
if someone's an expert at something and
has just done that for 30 years
the odds of them really wanting to
change a lot are pretty low and when
you're in a really Dynamic industry
that's a problem and so okay that was
like kind of my first revelation on this
and then when I looked to hiring
I can remember when I started my job we
needed cyber people and I go out there
and I look unemployment in the US was
almost 10 can't find them okay it's 10
and I can't find the people okay what's
the issue okay they're not teaching the
right things
that led me down a path and it was
Serendipity that I happened to do a
review of social Corporate social
responsibility we had this one little
fledgling School in a low-income area
and high school with a community college
we gave them internships Direction on
curriculum well behold we could hire
these kids
I said Hmm this is not CSR like I just
found a new talent pool which takes me
to now what I'm doing in my post you
know post retirement I'm like this idea
that don't hire just for a college
degree we had 99 of our hires were
college and phds and I'm all for it so
you're very don't I'm deeply excited no
you should not be I and I you know I'm
Vice chair at Northwestern one of the
device here but but I said I just really
like aptitude does not equal access
these people didn't have access but they
had aptitude it changed my whole view to
skills first and so now for hiring
that's kind of a long story to tell you
the number one thing I would hire for
now is somebody's willingness to learn
you know and you can test you can try
different ways but their curiosity and
willingness to learn hands down I will
take that trait over anything else they
have so the interview process the
question changes everything changed the
kind of things you talk to them about is
try to get at how curious they are about
testing and I mean there's we
triangulated around lots of ways and now
look they're at the heart of it what it
would do is change you don't think of
buying skills you see you think of
building skills and when you think that
way with so many people and I think this
country many developed countries being
disenfranchised
you got to bring them back into the
workforce somehow and they got to get
some kind of contemporary skills and if
you took that approach you can bring
them back into the workforce yeah I
think some interesting combination of
humility and passion because like you
said uh experts sometimes lack humility
if they call themselves an expert for a
few too many years so you have to have
that beginner's mind and a passion to be
able to aggressively constantly be a
beginner at everything and learn and
learn and learn you know I I saw it
firsthand when we were beginning this
path you know down the cloud in Ai and
we said and people say oh IBM you know
it's existential they've got to change
and all these things and and I did hire
a lot of people from outside very
willing to learn new things come on in
come on in
and I sometimes say shiny objects
trained in shiny objects come on in but
I saw something it was another one of
these you're not a shiny object I'm not
saying that it's uh but I learned
something okay some of them did
fantastic
and others they're like well let me
school you on everything but they didn't
realize like we did really Mission
critical work and then break a bank I
mean they would not understand the
certain kind of security and the
auditability and everything they had to
go on and then I watched IBM people say
oh I actually could learn something some
were like yeah okay I don't know how to
do that's a really good thing I could
learn and in the end there was not like
one group was a winner one was a loser
the winners were the people who were
willing to learn from each other I mean
it was to me it was very Stark example
of that point and I and I saw it
firsthand so that's why I'm so committed
to this idea about skills first and
that's how people should be hired
promoted paid you name it yeah the AI in
general it seems like nobody really
understand is now
what the future will look like we're all
trying to figure it out so like what you
know IBM will look like in 50 years uh
in relation to the the software business
to AI is unknown what Google will look
like with all these companies were
trying to figure it out out and that
means constantly learning
taking risks all of those things and
nobody's really skilled in AI It's like
because you're absolutely right that's
right I couldn't agree more with you on
that you uh you wrote In the book uh
speaking of hiring quote my drive for
Perfection often meant I only focused on
what needed to change without
acknowledging the positive this could
keep people from trusting themselves it
could take me a while to learn that just
because I could point something out
didn't mean I should
I still spotted errors but I became more
deliberate about what I mentioned and
sent back to get fixed I also tried to
curtail my tendency to micromanage and
let people execute I had to stop
assuming my way was the best or only way
I was learning the giving other people
control builds their confidence and
they're constantly trying to control
people destroys it so what's the right
balance between showing the way and
helping people find the way
that is a good question
because
like a really flip answer would be
as it gets bigger you have no choice but
to just you know you can't do it you
have to
you have to tell or show I mean
you've got to let people find their way
because it's so big you can't right
that's an obvious answer scope of work
bigger it gets okay I've gotta let more
stuff go
but
I have always believed that a a Leader's
job is to do as well
and I think there's like a few areas
that are really important that you
always do now it doesn't meaning you're
showing so like when it has to do with
values and value-based decisions like I
think it's really important to
constantly
show people that you you walk your talk
on that kind of thing is super important
and I actually think it's a struggle
young companies have because the values
aren't deeply rooted and when a storm
comes it's easy to uproot and
um so I always felt like when it was
that time I showed it I got taught that
so young as at IBM and even General
Motors that
um
I thought I write I do write about that
in the book first time I was a manager I
had a gentleman telling dirty jokes and
not to me but to other people and it
really offended people and some of the
women this is this is the very early 80s
and
they came said something I talked to my
boss I'm a first time manager and he was
unequivocal with what I should do he
said and this was a top performer it
stops immediately or you fire him so
there are a few areas like that that I
actually think you have to always
continue to role model and show right I
that to me isn't the kind that like when
do you let go of stuff right so the
values and relationships with with
clients yeah whatever you're in service
of and and the other thing was I really
felt was really important to role model
learning right so
you know I can remember when we started
down the journey
and we went on to this thing called it
think Academy IBM's longtime motto have
been think and we said okay I'm gonna
make the first Friday of every month
compulsory education
and okay I mean everybody like everybody
I don't care what your job is okay when
the whole company has to transform
everybody's got to get kind of have some
skin in this game and understand it I
taught the first hour of every month for
four years now nice okay I had to learn
something so
but it made me but I've like okay if I
can teach
right I mean I mean you know kind of
thing so it was a compulsory uh Thursday
night education for you oh a little bit
I'm a little better prepared than that
but yes you're so right yes